There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
from January to test for ourselves.
ELF has been killing it with
its new releases lately,
and we need to talk about
this new Power Grip Primer,
because it's excellent.
Immediately I compared it
to my Milk Hydro Grip Primer.
They are virtually identical
in terms of texture and how they apply,
except this ELF one is obviously cheaper.
Just like the Hydro Grip Primer,
it creates a really nice
tacky base for foundation
that's meant to make
your makeup last longer.
My foundation blended out
really nicely on top of this.
It wasn't pilling
or doing anything out of the ordinary.
I took some pictures
about five to six hours after I applied,
and I do think my makeup
lasted really well,
even my blush,
which is literally always the first thing
to disappear on my face.
ELF also released this powder foundation
in its Camo line.
I'll be honest: Powder foundations
are just not my thing.
I don't like how they look on my skin,
but the Camo line has
had nothing but hits,
so I had to try this.
The powder is so soft,
and it blends out very easily.
It definitely evened out my skin tone
and blurred some of those
areas I have of discoloration.
However, it just looks powdery!
I don't think it gives my skin
the most flattering texture.
I forgot to set it with some spray
to see if that helps at all,
but I don't see myself liking this,
even with setting spray
to melt it in a bit.
This is not for me.
I love trying new mascaras.
This is the Makeup Revolution
5D Lash Pow Mascara.
It's supposed to make it look like
you're wearing falsies.
The size of this brush is astronomical.
Oh, my God.
But I love a big
natural-bristle mascara brush.
Right away, I could tell
that this mascara was
doing a really nice job
of thickening my lashes.
And the more I built it up,
it gave my lashes this nice little curl.
I naturally have straight lashes,
and I hate curling them,
so I was really happy with the effect
this mascara gave them.
Also, I love how you push
the cap down to open it.
It's really satisfying to me.
The Fenty Beauty Killawatt
Freestyle Highlighter
is definitely not new,
but Madison Beer said she uses this one
in Ginger Binge/Moscow Mule as a blush,
and everyone bought it, including me.
Fenty highlighters are
more glittery than sheeny,
so I was a little nervous
about how this was going to look on me
and the texture on my cheeks.
It was definitely more metallic-looking,
because it's a highlighter
and not a blush,
but I actually did not hate this at all.
I did have to go over it with my sponge
to take away some of that glitter,
but the color and the glow
it brought to my cheeks
was super pretty.
I don't think you need
this specific product
for this kind of effect,
but if you're going to try it,
I recommend sticking to
the side with less glitter.
Charlotte Tilbury just dropped
this Beautiful Skin Foundation.
The claims on the box were so funny to me.
Like, "skin tone looks more
even by up to 210%" ...
sure.
This foundation had a
way thicker consistency
than I expected, and I
think because of that,
it didn't really melt into my skin
the way I wanted it to.
The coverage leaned more
on the lighter side,
so I went back into certain areas
and added some more.
It's definitely buildable,
but I'm not obsessed with
how my skin is looking.
I don't think it looks cakey,
it just looks like I'm wearing foundation,
and it's not as skin-like
as the name would have you think.
Do I think my skin tone looks more even
by up to 210%?
I can't really say,
but this is just OK to me.
I saw a TikTok that said
this Sigma Renew Lip Oil
is a possible dupe for
the $35 Dior lip oil,
so I had to compare the two,
because I am obsessed
with the Dior lip oil.
It feels so nourishing on the lips,
and it has that big doe-foot applicator
that feels so cushiony.
I could literally apply this all day.
The Sigma lip oil looks so much like it.
Look at these applicators.
They're almost identical.
The Sigma one is hydrating and shiny,
and it gives you that
moisturizing, non-sticky feeling.
It feels so much like the Dior one.
The only discernible difference
I found between the two
is that the Sigma one has no scent,
and the Dior one does.
It's $22, which is still
really pricey for a lip oil,
and it only comes in four shades,
but I think this is a really good dupe.
Highly recommend.
You guys have been asking me to try out
some Rare Beauty on this show,
so I picked up the new
Warm Wishes Effortless Bronzer Stick
and the Always an Optimist
Soft Radiance Setting Powder.
Let's talk about the bronzer stick first.
I immediately got nervous
swatching it on the back of my hand,
because it looked so red.
But I was so shocked
when I saw how easily it blended in.
I don't know why I applied this
like it was a contour stick,
but it worked out for me.
The texture of this is something special.
It's super smooth and soft and velvety,
and it doesn't blend into nothing.
You still see that color.
You still get the warmth of a bronzer.
It looked way less red
when I applied it to my face,
so I was actually really happy with this.
Now the setting powder.
I'll admit right now,
I made a mistake getting the medium shade.
I should've gone for light medium,
but I expected this to be way more sheer
than it actually was.
I normally use a translucent powder,
so using a setting powder with color
was new for me.
Applying it with my sponge
was an immediate no.
It made my skin look so patchy and weird.
My powder brush was
definitely the way to go.
The powder was super-finely milled,
and it gives your skin that soft blur
that looks really pretty.
It made my skin look a
lot smoother on the side
where I used my brush.
It's still a little
patchy in terms of color,
but that's obviously my fault,
because this is not my color.
I definitely need to try this again
in my appropriate shade.
And finally, let's talk about
the new NYX Thick It. Stick It! Brow Gel.
It's described as a
thickening brow mascara.
If you look really closely,
you can see those little fibers
that are supposed to make your brows
look fuller and fluffier.
I actually bought this for myself
and used it once and
thought it was just OK,
but I had no idea you
were supposed to layer it.
So I did that this time around,
and my brows came out so much better.
I'm obsessed with how
this right brow looks.
The left one, not so much,
but that's always my problem brow.
I kind of wish this had a smaller brush,
because I kept accidentally
spreading the product
outside of my brows.
But I do like the natural full effect
that you get with this.